je veux en préambule dire que je
souscris complètement jusqu'à moindre
virgule aux propos de laurence rossignol
tout à l'heure nous sommes prêts dans
une mâchoire et ce n'est pas vrai pas du
tout vrai que notre débat est
indifférent et que notre débat ne n'est
pas le symptôme d'un climat qu'il ya
dans ce pays une opportunité politique
pas pour régler un problème concret qui
nous empêche de vivre ensemble non
personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui que ce
qui nous empêche de vivre ensemble où le
problème en milieu scolaire de la
laïcité c'est les accompagnatrices
c'est avant tout et la multiplication
des enfants qu'on enlève du système
scolaire pour faire leur éducation à
domicile ou dans des écoles qui ne sont
même pas déclaré et on les en doctrine
oui
réfléchissons à comment on lutte contre
ça et puis je veux le dire vraiment dans
ce pays
il y à une montée du racisme anti
musulman oui ou non est ce que je suis
le seul est ce que nous sommes les seuls
à le voir nos noms quand monsieur
zemmour peut s'exprimer en direct sur
lci
comme monsieur zemmour a pignon sur rue
quand monsieur zemmour peut de façon
accepté chroniqué dans la presse
française tranquillement alors qu'il a
été condamné pour incitation à la haine
religieuse et que le racisme n'est pas
une opinion à débattre mais un délit
quand on est dans cette situation
alors on regarde l'opportunité des
débats et je suis intransigeant dans la
lutte contre l'islamisme politique
je répète aujourd'hui à quelques jours
de l'anniversaire que je reste charlie
et que les et que ceux qui ont été tués
à ce moment là étaient mes amis mais je
ne peux pas ne pas voir que si nous
regardons l'histoire de ce pays et de
cet hémicycle qui s'est battu pour la
loi de 1905 qui s'est battu au moment de
la loi falloux relisez les débats
qui a été soutenu massivement par sens
commun dans une dans une campagne
électorale qui a mobilisé les églises et
tout le réseau privé catholique pour
aller contre le mariage homosexuel
contre la loi sur l'avortement qui alors
je vous le dis je vous le dis très
tranquillement dans ton cul celui là
dans un débat comme celui là il faut
compter vérité ou six morts ou problèmes
à lille il faut conclure je vois que les
grands laïque tolérant mais les parents
les ailes